love story continues and 480 viewers a
special invitation to the ceremony this
is a pretty big deal and we've made it
let's let's renew this this commitment
to each other what do you say ha ha ha
ha Trista's dress silver gray with
floral sequence by pavani I fell in love
with it the second that I saw it and my
pinky moment the two special
participants
with her daddy four-year-old Blakeslee
should we practice our special walk and
giving away mom
six-year-old max my favorite part of the
ceremony is going to be including our
kids I'm such a proud mom playing for
the reception
airing Sunday on ABC from Beaver Creek
Colorado a four-tiered cake king of
white roses under an open beam ceiling
deck with chandeliers and ryan taking
pictures of everything
nailed it that's keeper he opens the
vault to see how they made it ten years
the water cooler moment she and I are
Mets me together Trista seems ready to
pick a slick financial analyst Charlie
but then let me know she picks Ryan the
shy firefighter waiting after the
wedding and after having two kids Krista
shows off her post-baby body on more
than one magazine cover
she also don't sell rarity in a Brad
Paisley video swingers
Trista's look today not much changed
when 10 years ago Ryan a little thinner
hair shorter as for the vows I pulled
out my vows from before I really liked
the vows that I said the first time
beaver Creek's we have a problem with
how we decided at the condo not to do in
period so I didn't bring my